في عام 2001 ، كانت البيئة
مختلفة كثيرًا بسبب انهيار dot-com ،
لذلك واجهت جمع المزيد من الأموال
أو الاستغناء عن الموظفين ، لذا مرة واحدة
كان لدي اجتماع مع VC محتمل واحد
من أقوى الأشخاص
الذين طلبهم  زجاجة نبيذ بخمسة آلاف دولار
وقلت إنك تعلم أنك لا
تحتاج حقًا إلى طلب زجاجة النبيذ هذه
لأنني لا أشرب ولم أستطع
حتى أن أتذكر عدد المرات التي
امتلأ فيها الكأس فجأة
ينقل لي مدى انجذابه
إليّ ، وأنا أعلم تمامًا أنه
قبلني حقًا وسحبت بعيدًا ، ولن أنساه أبدًا
عندما لمسني تحت
الطاولة ونظر في عيني
وأمسك بقدمي وعصرها وأقول إنك تعلم  سأساعدك ،
سأفعل هذا من
أجلك ، قلت إنه كان مخلصي أو
شيء من هذا القبيل ، وفي نفس الوقت
ينتهكني ، التقيت به لتناول المشروبات
للتحدث عن هذه الفرصة التجارية المحتملة
بعد أن عدت إلى المنزل لاحقًا  ذلك
المساء في الساعة 1:00 صباحًا تلقيت رسالة نصية
من  طلب مني أن
أعود لمقابلته مرة أخرى في بار الفندق الخاص به ،
فتحت عيني تجاهله نوعًا ما ،
وبحلول ديسمبر من عام 2016 ، كان
المال ينفد ، لذا التقينا به وهذه
المرة أحضرت شريكي المؤسس  سيدة
معي ، لذلك نذهب إلى بار الفندق هذا ، لدينا
مشروبات وكانت هذه هي اللحظة التي شعرت
فيها بساق ساقي تحت المنضدة
التي اعتقدت أنها حقيقية
كما لو أنها حذرتني مرة أخرى
لقد حذرتني تمامًا ولكني لم أفعل  لم أتوقع
أن يكون الأمر وقحًا للغاية ، فقد كنت محظوظًا بما يكفي لأن
يكون لديّ مستشار أو مرشد لم
يعرب أبدًا عن أي اهتمام رومانسي أو جنسي
بي ، وكنا
نعمل حرفيًا على جداول البيانات ، وهو أقل
شيء مثير في العالم أتذكره نحن
جالسون  جنبًا إلى جنب أمام
الكمبيوتر وفي نهاية ذلك
وقف وهو وسحب
عضوه التناسلي المنتصب كان محرجًا وكان
الأمر غير مريح ولكنه كان غير عادل ولكنه
حدث ولم يكن آخر ما
أقوم به.  م سيحدث شيء من هذا القبيل
عندما يفعل ذلك ويجعلني أفعل
هل تشعر بالاشمئزاز ، هل أنت على قيد الحياة وهذا
محترم مثل كل إنجازاتي
التي جمعت بالفعل خمسة ملايين
دولار في تمويل المشاريع كما لم يكن أيًا من
ذلك مهمًا ، لا أصدق أنه بعد
كل هذه السنوات لا يزال يؤلمك تعلم